tulsi gabbard and alexandria Ocasio
cortez back universal basic income in
response to coronavirus this to me
that's interesting it's interesting but
it bothers me it feels like such a cheap
shot to take advantage of the crisis as
an excuse to shoehorn in universal basic
income won't work
I mean politicians have been doing that
forever right right no AOC tried to do
exactly this with the green new deal
right it literally said that when that
dude is leaving when he was out on his
ear they're like this is what we hope to
do right
well psychic chakra bright yeah he said
so this is her advisor he gave an
interview where he said the green new
deal is not even about the environment
it's about changing the economy okay so
here you have all these people being fed
this line that were fighting for the
environment and the real thing in it if
you actually read it was social justice
leftist politics and economic reform
they were talking about free health care
free college it was it they put green in
front of it it was a trick yeah so
here's the thing I actually think the
ubi kind of idea right now is a
temporary measure it's not universal
basic income they're calling it that
this I actually think is a bad idea
no I agree it I mean if we're gonna have
to shut everything down for two months
they're saying it's gonna last two
months it's like all right so give
everyone like you know a slice but you
have thousand bucks is it a week a month
or one that was not even that much yes
not much what maybe is a good amount of
money but it's like for two months to
give everybody a thousand bucks a month
to survive over this next two months is
pretty great here's why I think this one
makes sense for one it's basically the
economic stimulus we saw under Obama I'm
not saying that's a good idea what what
I'm saying this isn't me very very
different from general universal basic
income but it's temporary yeah it's a
short-term thing and people can't work
anyway exactly what everything temporary
with the government always ends up being
perfect I know that's why I'm saying I
don't like it yet time to shoehorn this
in yeah the general idea though its
merits is basically tons of people are
to be out of work so giving people you
know some kind of insurance will come
something you know taken out of the
American the US coffers to ensure that
people can get basic supplies make sense
in the very short term yeah but you're
right
I don't like this because I think what
the lineup doing is being like well now
that we have it I mean it works right
everyone loves it yeah well everyone
loves it but then they're gonna get lazy
and not not work anymore
it's not even about that it's it's about
the the how the economy works in terms
of low-skilled labor and and market
demand once you explain that we will let
me read this and I'll explain to
everyone why universal basic income
makes doesn't work and I'm somebody was
a big fan of yang but still critical of
his plan what he was proposing made a
little bit more sense bug into that they
say okay Zhu Cortez and Tulsi Gabbard
are calling for universal basic income
in response to the growing kovat 19
pandemic gabbard introduced legislation
on friday that would provide a ubi
payment of $1,000 per month to every
American adult until the Department of
Health and Human Services declares the
outbreak over and there it is the
outbreak will never be over right that's
how they keep it going yeah the corona
virus pandemic has created a threat to
the health and well-being of the
American people as well as to our
country's economic stability while some
in Washington are focused on taking care
of Wall Street every day Americans are
getting left behind that's wrong said
Gabbard in a statement now that I agree
with ya you know we're seeing great
concern over well III agree to an extent
I do think Trump is trying to propose
like payroll tax cuts and stuff like
that yeah so I think it's not entirely
fair but there are definitely people
much more concerned about oil industry
quote I've introduced a resolution that
prioritizes people so our economic
relief is placed directly into the hands
of every American rather than getting
stuck in bureaucracy or ending up in the
pockets of big corporations they go on
to say the idea of ubi was recently
popularized by Andrew yang who proposed
monthly $1,000 payment although not as a
temporary emergency measure AOC took to
Twitter on Thursday to express her
support for ubi as one of several
programs intended to help ease financial
burdens during the crisis this is not
the time for half-measures we need to
take dramatic action now to stave off
the worst public health and economic
effects tweeted okazu cortes on Thursday
that includes making moves on paid leave
debt relief waving work requirements
guaranteeing health care and here you go
you know what man I just I cannot stand
everything that happens is a sleazy
NIP y elation for her disgusting
ideology it really really pisses me off
you know you won't have an honest
discussion about health care and
improving people's lives I'm down but
when you want to take advantage of
people's fears to shoehorn in your
stupid ideas that don't work you're
gonna get me angry yeah I could see that
anyway although passing you bi could be
a tall order even during a national
emergency more conventional relief
efforts we're moving through Congress
with some difficulty House Democrats
introduced a bill intended to alleviate
financial burdens by providing paid sick
leave boosting unemployment benefits and
providing nutritional aid while
guaranteeing free tests for Kovan 19
well there we go right the measure was
initially opposed by Republicans and
President Donald Trump who said that the
that the omission of unspecified certain
things meant the bill was unacceptable
Nancy Pelosi announced Friday evening
Democrats had come to an agreement with
Trump although details were not
immediately available Trump has been
pushing to cut payroll taxes in response
to the crisis critics including
lawmakers from both parties largely
dismissed the idea saying the plan
didn't go far enough while noting that
it won't do anything to help workers who
are sick or laid off to the virus I
completely agree with that yeah Rokon
and Tim Ryan proposed separate
legislation Friday that would use an
Earned Income Tax Credit to provide an
emergency payment of between one
thousand and six thousand to anyone who
earned less than 65 K last year I don't
like that either
we must soften the blow for workers as
large gatherings and events are canceled
and hours are cut a payroll tax cut is
not sufficient okay okay we get the
point
I don't like how they do these these
benefits based on where you were last
year right we're facing a major
emergency people are out of work people
are being told to stay home people need
help now based on their bills now right
if you bought a house the beginning of
this year and you got a mortgage now you
didn't have last year and you did it
because you got a raise in January
saying but you were only making X last
year so we're not gonna get where I can
help you that makes no sense right but
anyway let's talk about you bi huh you
know sure here's the simple problem if
every single person is guaranteed a
thousand dollars we're not people seem
to think that money is it's like magic
but they don't realize as money
represents the the supply and demand
system itself if somebody is getting if
somebody has no money and needs access
to food
they will work to get money to buy the
food but the value of the food is based
on the lowest cost for someone to
produce it right everyone has a thousand
dollars they might as well have zero
because you need to say to someone I'm
going to give you X so that you produce
Y let's say so I'll try and I'll try
break this down if everybody it's a
thousand dollars then all of a sudden
the people who normally made a thousand
bucks per month working part-time in
McDonald's say I don't need to work
there anymore
right I got my bills or paid I got my
phone I got my apartment I'm gonna go
skate all of a sudden McDonald's is like
we lost our employees so they say hiring
nobody shows up nobody needs it because
they already make a three thousand bucks
right now even though you can make money
on top of the ubi they still say I don't
care thousand bucks covers my rent
covers my phone and I got my skateboard
so McDonald's then says ok $2,000 a
month part-time now someone says whew
that's not bad I'll take it then
McDonald's says ok to cover the cost of
that our dollar burger is now our 3
dollar burger hmm then a guy who works
the office across the street walks in
and says I'm gonna get 3 bucks for the
for the value menu man prices are going
up these days huh so he goes back to his
boss and he says look I can't even
afford to get lunch anymore on this
entry-level salary could give me a raise
and the boss says I can't afford to do
it he says well I'm gonna quit News all
right fine I'll give you the raise it's
gonna hurt us but I'll do it then he
goes to his vendors and says I had to
give all my employees raises that's why
ubi doesn't make sense
yeah it's not that people are gonna be
lazy and stop working there's gonna be a
lot of so is this a well actually yes
sort of but it's that the lowest cost
for production is what sets the value of
minimum wage the numbers is essentially
meaningless right okay so it's like one
of the ways I describe is imagine
there's a baker right they went to
school for two years for culinary arts
they go work at a Whole Foods and they
get paid $15 an hour mm-hmm the minimum
wage is 10 bucks an hour
the janitor makes ten bucks the person
who picks apples gets ten bucks an hour
which means if they can pick one apple
per hour it's ten it's ten dollars plus
per Apple I'm just giving hypotheticals
obviously apples on cause it much yeah
yeah so now the guy who owns the the
farm says we got to cover all of the
costs its $15 per apple that means the
lowest level worker can't even buy one
Apple with one hour of labor because the
costs on top the Baker can well all of a
sudden they say we're raising all the
minimum wage to $15 an hour now the guy
who makes who grows the apples and picks
them has to get paid five dollars more a
30% increase yeah that hits everybody
and all of a sudden the baker can't
afford it buy apples anymore goes to his
boss and says I can't afford to buy
apples anymore need a raise so the boss
gives him a raise increases the cost of
everything else after the fact you know
so that's why it's a circle just right
coming around it does make sense in
certain contexts like if we do increase
the costs it'll have an effect on
imports and exports so computers that
are made overseas will stay the same
price because there's no minimum wage
for the slave labor in at Foxconn in
China which is what the you know the
people in these big corporate elites
wanted they wanted them to work for
slave wages in China where they're like
committing mass suicide I'm not
exaggerating so that they could sell a
$3 phone in America for 700 bucks right
so it doesn't work but let me let me let
me tell you something else
to all the people who are really really
excited about ubi how many people do you
know want to be musicians um not that
many enough right
I know a few people yeah are they all
really are they all good enough to be
musicians no and what if they were given
money and told that you can do whatever
you want what they say not living in van
down by the river and right so it's it's
it's this is the dream of like these
utopianist far leftists who think I
should be allowed to literally do
anything even if it produces nothing
right how many people I know are just
not good at you know music or
skateboarding or whatever and they're
like I'm gonna be the best dude I know
some people everybody thinks that not
everyone yeah everyone thinks that
they're amazing to an extent I mean
there's there there there there are
people musicians that I know that want
to be musicians all think that and
they're not and they're not otherwise
they would be exactly there's so much
you need to be successful in you know
music or acting or whatever right I use
those examples because they're easy
examples sure everybody knows that bro
who knows three chords and wrote some
dumb song and he's like
and you're like you're never gonna be
you like you're it's it's not good I
know a lot of people that are just not
good and they're still trying I know and
bless their hearts because assistance
well right perseverance is important but
there's also you still do need other
things yeah so look I play music you
know I think I'm pretty good you play
music I think you're pretty good
we're not pro musicians and we and we
and we got some good music and people
have been clamoring like let's hear you
play yeah and they're pretty good yeah
but there's so much more involved to
being successful in music through that
so you get all these people who live in
their parents basements and then you say
we're gonna be a thousand bucks a month
like I'm gonna quit my job and play
music now yeah and now you're gonna have
a thousand you know you know ten million
really awful acoustic singers begging to
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be
completely imbalanced because you're
creating an economy based on what people
think we need versus what we actually
need
yeah and it's almost like college did
something similar and now we have an
imbalance where we need more we need
traits we need carpenters we need
contractors any plumbers electricians
and what do we get trade schools are the
liberal arts feminist dance class
degrees I'm not even exaggerating I know
it's so funny
so look III I like the idea I think what
we're really talking about is not ubi
and and I'm kind of like I'm offended by
this and I think toesies great I like
Tulsi but this is this is a no-no I have
no problem criticizing the people that I
think you know if it if it is only just
for a little bit like just and then it's
it's a stimulus yeah then it works oh
man it makes sense remember the stimulus
check everyone got do you remember that
I don't know I got a check in the mail
from Obama I don't know how much was
before but I was like free money my
college ended and it was it was meant to
make everyone start spending to get
things moving yeah and I don't know if
it worked or not all guys good I don't
know I don't know it didn't work I don't
think it did a bunch Pierre talks a lot
about supply-side economics to the way
to really stimulate the economy is to
help the companies and to make it easier
for them to make products affordable for
people and then people will be able to
spend their money I'll make it
affordable by going overseas and not
necessarily so if you cut red tape in
the US companies will be able to stay
here right carrier and Ford they will
stay in they're forced to do terrible
yeah
exactly so there's things you can do
that our shipped overseas no I don't I
don't I don't get it like so here's the
thing about Andrew yang what he was
talking about was a dividend essentially
a vet tax on these big tech companies
there's a lot missing from what he was
talking about but he has a decent idea
Alaska for instance does pay a dividend
to all of its to all's residents from
oil profits oh I think it's you know how
much it is it's like three grand per
year or something how much yeah yeah
it's some small sum and it seems to work
pretty well for them yeah I don't know
much of oil companies go and work and
then the residents gave me my life's
pretty slow up there I've been to Alaska
it's it's chill and everyone's just kind
of I heard everything is really
expensive because they're like you can
make really good money if you go up
there and do the job that I was doing
and I was like well why why can I make
that much money they're like oh yeah the
cost of living is like five times what
it is they just they just want girls to
move back there I was told I was told by
the locals that there's like five guys
everyone right now because all the girls
leave and go to like the mainland
so here's here's what what actually
makes sense in it to a certain degree
with a ubi is if you be I was funded
based only on exports Oh interesting if
other countries had to pay a tax or like
well you know it trickles down I guess
but if a part was going to be sold made
in America to another country they had
to pay a premium and that tax would then
be dispersed as a dividend to the
American people that's the closest we
get to making sense of that but you
start one of the same problems if now
you have a bunch of guitar playing
hippies who are a lot I'm gonna quit my
job working at the cafe and I get a
bunch of cafes no employees and so it's
it's it's it's a hard injection to you
know this is why command economies don't
work because supply and demand really is
the important you know machinery of an
economy I think a mixed economy makes
the most sense we need some regulation
we need you know we need government
programs and and and like a referee
essentially you know where we draw the
line is interesting I've had some good
arguments with libertarians about this
stuff for the most part though I don't
think the people who have actually you
know looked at the ubi have actually
looked into it and they just like this
sounds great wine we just do it
yeah it does sound good the problem is
taxing people to pay people makes no
sense how does that make sense
we're gonna take money from you and then
give money to you that's that do you
know what the second law is it the
second law of thermodynamics energy in a
closed system yeah how do you take a
closed system of a hundred people and
give them all a thousand bucks a month
you'll the tax them more than that to
pay for the administration of the
bureaucracy yeah so it literally makes
no sense yeah so there's a bunch of ways
they've talked about making it work I
don't know man I've never been a really
really big fan but I will say I was
completely dismissive of it until yang
start talking about VAT taxes dividends
and Alaska and then I said actually
there is a way that you could do
something similar it wouldn't it
probably wouldn't be a thousand bucks a
month but if we treated American
industry like Apple exports you know
they they send all their labor to China
for the production and it's out back to
us if they had to pay a tariff on that
that still made that mix low made it
worth their while and then we got a cut
of that back to us that would make more
sense yeah still I don't think I have
all the answers all I know is there are
too many roadblocks for these ideas and
more importantly they're not talking
about ubi they're talking about a
stimulus or or in unemployment benefits
for people who are put out by the bio
might not want to work like in the green
new deal if you don't want to get a job
you know that cover you yeah that was in
there the frequently asked questions
they published for the green new deal
said that they were wilted that the bill
would provide economic security for
those unwilling to work man what yep
it's like that's kind of why I don't
want universal health care because I
don't want to pay for people who are
unhealthy you go to great lengths I do
to eat healthy right I think you eat
your vitamins absolutely and they want
you to pay for some fat dude riding
around in a little motor scooter eating
a hoagie in a Walmart yeah and drinking
beer can't stand it and they're like you
know you got to pay for men it's like it
works in Sweden because there's like
less than eight million people there
yeah but but but people in sweet now
people in Sweden also are all healthy
relatively healthy and they care about
their there yep environment too
and they're the largest largest per
capita exporter of weapons in the world
that is also true that's not the point
I'm making them yeah as Sweden is
exporting tons of weapons they the
government makes money that they can
redistribute among their sit there their
citizenry yeah that's why I was like
okay I ubi kind of thing might make
sense
I don't think ubi makes them makes the
most sense but look hey man we sell a
ton of weapons Trump was talking about
it you know these companies are gonna
sell to Saudi Arabia why don't why don't
we take those profits so yeah what up it
works in Alaska there it's called a the
Alaska Permanent Fund and it works
because they have so many natural
resources that's just like companies
come and ravage their environment not
necessarily but yes yeah I mean I don't
know about that
but yeah that's the only reason it works
there and I'm guessing it would work
somewhere like Norway has similar
natural resources small small
populations that are mostly culturally
homogenous yeah we can't compare to
other we have so many people here well
we're huge yeah that's that's the thing
that always bugged me too because I've
been to Europe a lot in my life and
people are always like oh you're
American I know exactly who you are
no idea you realize that I don't date is
like a different country it really is
somebody help me it's that listen listen
oh yeah that's great
somebody hit me up okay and they were
like hey I'm heading to Los Angeles next
month and I wanted to reach out and see
if you were available to meet up and I
said bro I live in I live in these
coasts and they were like yeah it's no
problem and I was like oh are you gonna
fly out here and they were like no I
figured you know I could you drive out
it's a 36 hour drive no it's it's forty
eight forty forty plus with more yeah
and I was like you realized that it's
like forth that was like four thousand
miles no I think it's like 3,500 miles
here's what here's oh it's not 4,000
well I got to read those I explained to
them I'm like that's thousands of miles
I had a friend who asked me they were
like when I come visit do you want to
drive down to Texas and I was like whoa
that's a long drive that's that's 30 37
hours I'm like I was in New York time
I'm like I don't know if I can take off
that much time for
work man and they're like what do you
mean I was like how long will it take to
get there
and I was like dude 36 hours of driving
straight yeah without stopping and they
were like wait well like 36 hours from
here to Arizona because I just did that
drive like two weeks go yeah so and its
2,400 miles from here to Arizona so it
can't be 4,000 yeah you're right you're
right 3,000 it's it's in both instances
people in Europe have a country like
France yeah and they assume France and
the United States as both being
countries are the same thing France is
about the size of Texas oh my Texas is
its own country oh yes and the people
that are actually really awesome you
know
Texans are cool people when you're in
Paris it's a couple hours drive till to
London I know I Drive around I Drive
around Europe and it's like four hours
I'm in a new country four hours later
I'm in a different country faith
committee different cultures they
thought yeah that driving from New York
to Texas would be like driving from
Paris to like Marseille or something
yeah which would be like four or five
hours like no no like that's crazy
that's like cute no they don't they
don't realize the United States is more
like all of Europe yeah that the states
are very very different it's basically
the EU essentially I mean in only in
saying how its separated it's a
different look at the United States
they're rather divided at the moment
Texas was a country the Republic of
Texas for several years like the history
of many of these different parts of the
US are very very very different the Lone
Star State yeah yep so you end up with
people in Europe not realizing it and
then you end up with these urban Falk or
like if Denmark can do it why can't we
because Denmark has what like three
million people Denmark's tiny it's like
if you tiny so here's my proposal though
okay New York give universal health care
to all people in New York including
those who don't live there yeah because
they've talked about California is
giving health care to people who are non
non citizens under the age of 26 huh
so New York should have no problem if
they all believe this yeah to give free
health care to all of its citizens and
anybody who comes on set yeah absolutely
let's get right on it why don't they do
it put the pedal to the metal no I'm
dead serious why why won't New York you
know what's impossible yeah they do I
don't have an answer yeah they know
could you imagine what could you imagine
what would be like if all of a sudden
they said anyone can come to any
Hospital free of charge that would be
insane you're gonna first of all you're
gonna get a bunch of hypochondriacs
treat me you're gonna see massive wait
times you're gonna see a reduction in
care people are gonna die and here's the
challenge because there's a hard reality
that people don't seem to understand
some people won't get health care no
matter what resources are finite I wish
it weren't true but it is yeah and we
can pretend all day and night but what
bothers me about this stuff about the
Socialists and aoc and these other
people who are like we should be giving
universal health care is like dude there
is no system where everyone gets health
care period that's an ideal that we
cannot achieve it's like it's like a
little kid being like why does it the
government just give everyone money cuz
then like then they can have whatever
they want and you're alive it doesn't
sound like that because people have to
make this stuff know like you just go to
the store and like you can buy the food
but the food has to be made by someone
but the store just has food like why
don't want the stores just give the
people food it's so dumb and you're like
okay all right we need Star Trek
replicators boom yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you